foreign  tell me why have you come here  [Music]  let's all cure ourselves of the entire  Cult of the absolute  people like you  people with parasites in their brains  all the way here from Baldur's Gate  you may just be the godsend we've been  praying for  foreign you're the same as me  you have a mind flare tadpole in your  brain let's try to find a solution  together before it's too late  [Music]  about you but it's a memories I need a  tempest  and I your only chance of survival  the hero so badly fine  let's make this interesting  fight we die and we just hope that when  our time comes there is someone else to  take our place  my this place is fun  [Music]  someone I want you to meet a friend who  sees the world in simple terms not just  a friend  a legend  he's not the kind of man who takes  kindly to captivity  the cult captured him  I almost feel sorry for them  [Music]